e
we're waiting for our Clerk and if she
doesn't show up soon um representative
yella has agreed to take notes for us so
we we'll start in uh we'll start in a
patience
e
okay good afternoon everyone um I Let's
uh call this meeting to order oh there
here okay terrific thank you um yes our
clerk has arrived okay so I'm GNA call
the meeting to order and um um why don't
we um start by um having the
representatives and Senator introduce
ourselves so that you know who we are um
this is being recorded and it's on live
stream so you know if you're in the
witness protection program or you know
you don't like to see people you don't
want people to see the faces you're
making with somebody said something you
disagree with
it uh so we're going to get started and
um so uh Senator when you begin by
introducing yourself good afternoon
everyone I'm Denise rardy and I'm the
state senator for district nine and I
was the sponsor in the Senate to have
this committee come forward and I'm
really so happy to to see all of you
today and I'm looking forward to finding
some really good solutions to improve
the quality of life for families with
disabilities thank you um my name is
Kathy stabb I am a state representative
from Manchester I represent Hillsboro
District 25 which is W
five and I am Jessica lontine a state
representative from Dober New Hampshire
which is straford District
17 and um I'm the proud stepmother of um
a daughter with Down syndrome and have
worked with her
to uh found find housing find a housing
solution for her that's taken quite a
few years but we're in a good place now
and I hope I can work to do this across
the
state hello my name is uh representative
Josh Ella and I am a state repres
restive
representing uh District uh Rockingham
District 32 uh which comprises the towns
of Fremont Danville and brenwood and I'm
on the special committee on
housing thank you okay thank you
everyone okay so the first order of
business on our um agenda is to approve
the minutes of the previous meeting um
corrections I have a couple couple of
minor
one one is the um it says the rural uh
Garden housing in conquered it's
actually the Royal Garden housing and um
Lisa bodin's name is b a u d o i
n yeah all
right is is there anything
anything else can I have a a motion to
approve the
minutes so moved okay move by Senator
richardi can I have a second I'll second
that and second by representative
yella okay in all in favor I all those
opposed okay the okay the minutes have
been approved okay the next thing we
have on our agenda is um a a
presentation from Chris shot who is um
fair housing director of New Hampshire
legal assistance if you would come
forward to the
microphone and turn on the red light
thank
you good afternoon members of the
committee my name is Chris shot and I'm
from New Hampshire Legal Assistant I'm
the fair housing direct director at that
project
nhla is a private nonprofit organization
focused on the legal representation of
indigent individuals in New Hampshire
including assisting victims of domestic
violence assistance with government
benefits assisting seniors facing
exploitation and eviction defense nhla
is also New Hampshire's only fair
housing initiatives program this is a
program created by the Federal
Department of Housing and Urban
Development to fund organizations at the
state level who assist with enforcing
the fair housing act as such we receive
funds from HUD to conduct Outreach and
enforcement regarding the Fair Housing
Act here in New
Hampshire the federal fair housing act
and our state law against discrimination
protect tenants and home buyers against
discrimination in housing thus making it
illegal for housing providers to take
adverse actions or treat people
differently due to their membership in a
number of protected classes the federal
protected classes are race color
national origin religion sex familial
status and disability with our own state
law additionally protecting marital
status gender identity sexual
orientation and
age while nhla provides assistance for
any indent person facing discrimination
regardless of what protected class they
fall into it is fair to say that the
most common fair housing intakes that we
receive are people um the people that we
most often represent are those facing
potential disability
discrimination nationally in 2022 53% of
all complaints filed with HUD or similar
fair housing agencies were disability
related for New Hampshire generally and
new nhla specifically um we see even
higher rates of reports of disability
discrimination for example in NHL's
Grant period And I apologize because
these are not on a calendar basis but
between June 2022 and may 2023 we
received 92 intakes regarding potential
fair housing issues um regarding mental
or physical disability this represented
77% of our fair housing intakes during
that period the next Grant period of
June 2023 to May 2024 saw an increase to
119 mental or physical disability
intakes representing 87% of our fa fair
housing intakes that year it is true
today that those with disabilities face
significant barriers in housing whether
it's denied accommodations or not being
able to access the services necessary to
live independently we are hopeful that
by hearing others lived experiences and
the barriers that these people face this
committee will recommend constructive
policy changes to assist those who faced
housing challenges due to their
disabilities I'm welcome to share any
more of nh's personal experiences and
representing clients facing disabil
discrimination and welcome any questions
I might be able to answer okay thank you
does anyone have any questions
for Mr
shot oh I do um um the people who come
forward with disability claims of um um
again
um what what what what is the nature of
those things are are they being evicted
did um are people are landlords not um
willing to provide
accommodations um are they you know are
they unwilling to allow um service
animals what kinds of um complaints are
you receiving from folks in the
disability Community yes definitely all
across the board and definitely what you
um the the ones that you just mentioned
um I'll say that we are unique in terms
of a fair housing initiales program
because we are a legal aid organization
as well so we do do a lot of focus on um
eviction defense so often times what
we're we're having when it comes to
disability discrimination when it comes
to eviction are situations where um a
person is being evicted either for a
lease violation or for a threat to
health or safety where there are
situations caused by their disabilities
that are leading to things that would be
material violations of a lease or
potential threats to health or safety so
um oftentimes we're seeing people who
might have a disability that leads to
hoarding um you know they that that can
lead to some something where you know
that that could lead to eviction other
times where there might be um either bio
issues or um other situations where
there could be a dispute between um
tenants but it's directly related to
their their disability under um there's
a there's a specific federal district of
New Hampshire law that that protects um
tenants who are being evicted due to
these reasons that might be disability
related um and so we often step in to
essentially ask for an accommodation to
allow people more time and especially to
just get Services set up for people so
that they can live independently um so
that's one of the major areas that we
specifically represent in beyond that of
course we do absolutely step in to
assist people with accommodation
requests whether it's been a denial or
they just need help or guidance through
the process um we will step in to assist
with u making these requests for
accommodations or modifications and that
kind of wraps into as well what you were
talking about with service animals
because by their definition in housing a
an assistance animal is an accommodation
in of itself so we do see a fair amount
of those cases and and assist people
questions representative lontine I just
asked um will you be able to provide um
a written copy of some of your
testimony find that you're talking
really fast I apologize keep up with it
okay thank you
um um you mentioned
denials um how often is someone denied a
place to live because of a disability is
that is that common or is it mostly once
people are in apartments that they're
being yeah I I I think when I was saying
denials I was talking specifically about
accommodation requests denials or
modification request denials um so I I
would say you know I I wouldn't have the
numbers in front of me we um have
occasionally you know there will be
times where somebody has you know been
applying for a place and they are denied
a place because you know while they're
applying they ask for an accommodation
that does happen um I would point you
actually I think last week there was a
recent HUD charge in Manchester
regarding a a tenant who um they had a a
service animal with them and when they
went to do a a housing um a a tour of
the the house um the landlord demanded
that they have their paperwork on them
at that point before they had even
submitted their application um and when
they didn't have it immediately on them
they said they weren't going to rent to
them at all um so that was a recent um
charge that was there that was a
specific denial of housing beyond that
it's um you know a lot of times where a
land a request has been made for
accommodation or modification the
landlord has said no and then we will
get involved after we've received an
intake to see if we can try and um
resolve it you know and and get the
accommodation or modification secured um
when a landlord is asked to put in an
accommodation or
modification um are there
resources available to the landlords to
make that um you know for example if
someone needs a ramp or I mean some
things are you know like rails in the
bathroom and Etc but um what kind of
resources and help are available to
landlords when they are asked to provide
an accommodation yeah um so in terms of
at least just taking a step back to just
responsibility when we're going for a
modific which is a change to the
physical structure of of um a a a
building um if it's a private apartment
It generally is going to be
responsibility of the tenant to pay um
to pay for those modifications is if
it's a subsidized property then it would
fall on the the financial responsibility
of a a landlord to to provide that um
for tenants and landlords um out there I
believe that there is money through the
CFI program to provide it I I do
apologize I'm not exactly sure about you
know funding sources but I do know that
several of my clients um the money
actually hasn't been the problem it's
been you know at least some of the ones
that i' I've encountered it's been more
along the lines of um you know just a
person say a landlord telling them they
just could not install this ramp for for
example for other other reasons um so I
do know there's money out there but I do
know that it also can be a problem for
those who don't have money secured um C
can you tell me what CFI stands for
choices for Independence program it's a
Medicaid Program um that is it that it
will assist people with u disabilities
um in providing inhome supports for them
both you know I believe that it can
assist with um actual you know physical
change structure but it also will fund
um you know in in home um assist
assistance um so I I believe the idea
behind the program is that it it is it's
allows people to live independently stay
in their homes and um pay for assist pay
for assistance for people so that they
aren't um directed to assisted living
questions okay um thank you very much um
we have your contact information if if
we need further great thank you so much
we have any further questions we'll
reach out to you okay um okay all right
thank you um the next person that I have
on the agenda
is Kim
woke um Can Kim come
coming for your record can you both uh
State your names and um where you're
from hi good afternoon committee members
my name is Ben Saul
Sahl I'm the director of operations and
Council to Visions for Creative Housing
Solutions which provides Supportive
Housing for individuals with
developmental disabilities and related
conditions in the Upper Valley with
locations in Lebanon Enfield and
Hanover and with me is one of our
residents who would like to testify
today about her experience with housing
in New Hampshire Kim
wol w k all right thank you okay Kim
take it
away good afternoon committee members um
as I said um I'm Kim wal and I've been a
resident at Visions for Creative Housing
November oh
before Visions my housing was um in a
condo I was living by
myself
and apparently not
working for for me uh being
isolated um at Visions I have um friends
support I
don't fit
into um any one category of
disabilities um you know it's not
apparently obvious you know just by
meeting
me um on paper I look good but and yet I
live visions and there there is a
reason is being
alone uh was not the
me would you um do you have more to say
or were you willing to take some
questions I'm willing to take questions
okay all right can can I ask you um you
said you felt isolated in your other
apartment building um and you feel more
um uh you feel less isolated now that
you're living so how
um how do you how do you interact with
the broader community and how does
Visions help you do that where you
weren't getting that before in your
condo um Visions has helped me um in
many ways uh one of which is
employment and I do work
full-time uh I
independent and you were you um when you
lived in your condo were you doing those
things also yes I was but it's a lot
network um and how can you describe the
support network how how do what kind of
supports do you receive
um I have the support of my fellow
residents and the support of the direct
support professionals that are employed
at
Visions
okay does anyone have any other
questions I do okay rep
Senator um so through the course of our
committee meetings there has been
different schools of thought one is you
know that we want this what people are
saying in this room we don't want all
people with disabilities in
one space we want them to be able to
mingle and mix and have Independent
Living then I hear your story which
sounds like it works better for you to
be in a group with uh other people that
share the same concerns you do so I'm
think thinking that one of the problems
is we're going to have to figure
out an opportunity for both to
exist and give people the choice that
want to live in a community where some
people have disabilities and some don't
but then provide services and
communities like Visions for those who
prefer to all be um together I am I am I
hearing this correct from these meetings
yeah so what you have works for you yes
that's not necessarily what every single
person or family would like to achieve
so we're going to have to find solutions
for both I guess is my takeaway right
um there
are I think the um the support is
tailored at Visions to fit the needs of
the individual resident and my needs are
U might be less than
you yeah so one of the things that we
have
um
the the Restriction of creating um um
housing that's specifically for people
with disabilities is that um they don't
have choice
about what they do on a daily basis so
do you feel like you have choices about
whether to access the supports when you
[Music]
um the residents at Visions they do have
um have choices
and if there's activity they want to do
then we then the um support staff tries
to
accommodate each
resident and yes I have uh the unique
position of being able
to decide oh I need to I would like to
do this and I could go and do it myself
or join the rest of the
outing
okay okay are does anyone have any
further
um yes so you stated that you were
living in a condo independently and that
wasn't working out for you um
was how hard I guess was it for you to
find this uh solution this uh that
worked out for you was was there um
Financial barriers was there
time uh were you put placed on a waiting
list how how was that transition from
you know needing support to
achieving uh that
support my um moving into Visions
happened in the very early days of its
uh
creation um so there was no uh weight
list um it was sort of a decision that I
just had to make make and like what was
best for me and for for my family
too um it's like can you know living
alone can I make this work and the
answer was no and so the the support
option okay um the setting that uh
Visions is in in the Enfield location is
um is sort of a a country you know home
used to be an
inn uh that the executive directors
parents
community where
you I live in one of the there's
three buildings on the site and I live
in one of them with two other
residents um Can were you were you
receiving Support Services in your condo
okay representative
y yes um so when you describe the home
that you're you're currently living in
you said that there is there's two other
individuals
is that um in that home are there like
separate apartments or is this kind of a
um where you have your own room but
there's a common limit living area there
yes there is um a common area there's a
shared
kitchen and a common living room I do
have my own space with a sofa and you
know TV and and my and my own space so
um Gatherings if you want to have
friends over but then there if you need
that and then do you most of your meals
okay yeah
um I eat um most of my meals there with
um with the fellow residents it would be
on the weekends mainly because I work
second shift
is that in your house oh that's in the
main
[Music]
house can I ask what you do for work I'm
a secondary assembler I work for
hypertherm oh okay in light industrial
consum plasma consumable
assembly
sweet okay does anyone have any other
questions okay now we have a list over
there of other people that were planning
to testify and if someone could bring me
that list or if you could oh you have
one more question I I I had a question
for Ben as far as like the makeup of
this this
um uh Visions um if if the uh we had
discussions before about how these types
of um facilities are regulated
and if it
sounds
um like this might be a licensed
um the licensed threshold for um what
was that the certification was three
people and then more than that had to be
licensed licensed yes so are you
licensed and is the structure um like
zoned commercial or is it they do they
consider it mixed use or is it um
considered residential how how is this
kind of site set up well I can't speak
to the zoning issue I can certainly look
into it and get back to you um the the
the certification and licensing issue as
I imagine you guys are aware is a is a
bit of a fraught
issue um at the threshold the the um
residences
in Enfield are currently certified which
they have been for over 10 years because
none of
the the
individual
apartments are house house more than
three
people
however uh the department has
recently um taken another look at how it
construes the uh um 151 I think it's a
and how that should apply so um they
have uh changed their view of our other
two locations which we have completed
licensing on and um we're quite
concerned about the nfield location
because particularly because of issues
like potential issues like
sprinkling U we have a um you know older
structures um which that could has the
potential to be um prohibitively
expensive and we also uh disagree with
the Department about uh the proper
issue okay go ahead
um when you're talking about
the the statute you're talking about the
the regul what kind of bucket you fall
into whether it's it's um certification
required or lure required or are you
talking about um some their
interpretation of a statute that might
require sprinklers or what are What
specifically were the former so all of
these locations are
certified the question is whether they
also need to be
licensed and there
are I I don't want to get too deeply
into the weeds
but we agree with what has always been
the view of the Bureau of certification
licensing at
DHHS which is that locations uh
certified
locations which house individuals with
developmental disabilities or related
conditions three or fewer are subject to
certification but do not require
licensing so they have
essentially taking the view that the the
issue is how many what's the headcount
Under One Roof rather than what's the
headcount in a
certified
location your your location as as was
previously described has three buildings
potentially each
with uh well there's three people in the
one building for sure that we have
already heard testimony for um are you
talking about um whether they might
count the multiple
buildings um kind of all as one location
and then make you fall under the
licensing even though they're
technically um different buildings and
so it's like different roofs no that's
not exactly the the way the issue is
presenting itself um the there are two
other
settings
that are potentially going to require
licensing one of them is a set of three
Apartments uh which are under is which
are in one
structure and then the other is that the
main house is connected to a you could
call it an accessory dwelling you could
call it a different structure but it has
a corridor which allows connection
between those buildings and so then the
question is you know does that put in
the view of the department all of these
an a number of individuals above
three Under One Roof and so would that
then require licensing with these
uncertainties around um you know the
fire protection issu the additional fire
protection issues which would rise under
licensing among also there are um in
addition to the initial hurdles there
are over 50 additional categories of
information docu M mentation which must
be uh maintained by a facility which is
subject to the licensing
regime uh rather than simply the
certification reg regime so it's subtle
subtle growth of you know
uncompensated uh administrative costs
issue thank you um
so I guess you didn't specifically State
this but I guess it was implied and so I
wanted to to bring it out um if these um
fac these uh this facility has three
three individuals housed um and is
licensed or uh is certified it doesn't
require sprinklers but if it was
required to be licensed that same
structure housing those same number of
people would require Sprinklers and
therefore would be an a financial burden
in on top of the the
requirements well first of all I would
say if you were building or rehabbing a
space now that was going to be certified
you'd almost certainly have to have it
sprinkler we we are talking about uh
an older
setting and I don't think you can speak
in absolutes about what is going to be
required
from whoever the Fire official is who is
you know ultimately
deciding what you have to do so it's
it's not totally cut and dry but what
we're looking at it from the perspective
of you know a risk that maybe
presented uh if you know so the other so
the settings which are licensed are
newer they one of them was a rehab and
one of them was a groundup build and
they're fully
sprinklered just as uh you know I think
contemporary um Market Apartments would
be I shouldn't say that I don't know
that that that that's necessarily the
case but these These are sprinkled but
the older these this older setting is is
not
and you know I'm I'm sure that people
could look at that and go like well they
should be you know and they're hardwired
to the local Fire Authority and people
could say and we do a lot of you know
fire drills you know everyone can get
out of there quickly so people could say
well you know you you can't have enough
fire safety and I certainly understand
that view but we also have a history of
you know 10 years of operating without
incident and you know you know under
certification you're required to do
periodic um fire drills that include
timing of uh getting individuals safely
out of the uh physical
site thank you for that I'm I'm
definitely clear curious about how it is
zoned because the um the we just
recently passed a law that um
essentially said that they can require
sprinklers for um residential like multi
family
uh dwelling units up
to for
three and I want to say three and four
unit structures and once you go past
Four there's a it's a whole different b
ball game but I think it I believe it
was recently uh a law was changed as far
as that and so if it's classifying you
as a multif family unit structure that
may um change but uh how you're kind of
what regulation you're allowed to be
imposed under um but if it's a a
commercial I think commercials is going
to more often require Sprinklers and so
it it would definitely be valuable if
you could follow up on that I'll do that
thank you thank
you does anyone have any more questions
for Kim and
Ben okay so we have a list over there of
other people that wanted to testify if
someone could bring that would be
terrific
yeah you can hand it to representative
you
okay all right let's see the first
person that I have on the list is Thomas
C
Wood just he just left okay um uh Laura
very
okay if you could just both state your
name for the record thank you yes hi my
name is Laura lilan Davies and I live at
Hampshire good afternoon my name is
Carrie Duran I'm the legislative liaison
for Lakes Region community services and
today go ahead whenever you're ready
okay
good
afternoon thank you for having us today
um again my name is Laura Laura I am
27 years old and I live with Bowman
Hampshire my whole entire
life and I went to um bont Regional
School District when I was
um when I was the senior at Bama High
School um I graduated in
2015 with no
diploma and then I recently
graduated um in 2018 with a regular
diploma um the high school um age
diploma is with kids with disabilities
they can graduate when they're 21 years
old um that was the first time for me
that I have experienced this um
but I'm very grateful that I got um all
the work done um and then I recently
went to University of New Hampshire um
for the union for you program and then I
graduated 223 last year in
May
um when people asked me about un and AG
what it is about
um I was the first with a disability who
went to college with r r
side
um and I was living in the
dorm for 2 years on campus um it was
very new to me
so um I had to take classes in and
everything but um the experience was was
fun also so
um my my degree was public
relations um which is a um science
degree but it's more for like
legislation stuff
um but during my time in high school I
did do a lot of internships I worked at
forell for 5 years
um
and now I'm
working at marab Basket in Tilton so I'm
so yes you want me to hold up for you
yes start there
um when people ask me about um what my
experience was like um let me tell you I
was homesick for the first time
it was hard for me but I'm excited
because I always wanted to go to school
and go to
college when I needed support I talked
to my all and Hall director and other
students I also time you zoom and my
family visit a
lot
um I loved having my own space I live
with people my own age and I got to do
what I wanted to
do I had a lot of
responsibilities I had to do my homework
clean my room and do a laundry and
having fun on CIS I use um
smartphone calendar alerts and apps like
Camp
technology helped me to be the most
independent that I had that I can be I
always knew
knew I always knew that un campus and
the fire station were were there nearly
if I need help for example I was stuck
on the elevator in the MB so I had to
call number one and the fire department
came to help me having that
support like that
and and help for part-time paid staff
and made it responsible for me to live
in theend me
more on
Kus but the biggest thing I wanted to
share is that I had access to so much
everything was Within in walking
distance I walked
independently to the dining hall in the
lodging room and rid it in hanford's
downtown restaurants in the stadium for
soccer and hockey
area took the welome P
whenever I
wanted I even had access to the m the m
changing I am here today to talk to talk
about a big issue that we face every day
a lack for
housing let me give you the facts after
college I wanted to stay at school with
my friends or move into my own place but
the fact is is that I couldn't afford
it though I work many hours a week I had
to move back home in
Belmont apartments are just too
expensive when I moved back home I was
very sad my friends are all far away I
Independence I had I had
to have my mom and other people drive me
to work bring me to the gym drive me to
meet my friends even if someone driv me
on dates it's
embarrassing it is hard for me to get
around because I don't have a driver's
license often times because I don't have
transation because I can't walk to
where I can't walk to where I'm going
FaceTime is zoom zoom is the only
choice I want to take the study
committee for continuing their hard work
and helping people with
disabilities and
drivers and
we there is no solution that works for
anyone like many people my age I don't
want to live in my parents
forever and having my own place on
campus I want I want to get it again in
the community
with in the
community I want and need access to
things that other people take for
granted it's like running to to the
store or getting together with my
friends after
work and not getting to work without a
cost of cost of $50 round
trip I want a apartment that is public
CH station closer together and I want my
Independence
back I'm here today to advice for
solution housing that is
Affordable in a part of the community I
need to get where I need to go and to
have things accessible to me I want to
community I am one
of I am one six of people who in the
country who got involved working on the
Fellowship I want I want to help you and
other people come up with
Solutions I test my file and contact
information project star star attack
please email me or or text me and let me
much thank you very much much um thank
you and thank you for providing written
testimony for us that really helps
especially our clerk um I just have one
uh quick question yeah um are you um
um are you committed to staying in
Belmont you said you work in Tilton
would would you be willing to move to
another community in that area in order
to get the things that you
need um I'm a to move anywhere in New
Hampshire State um I just I mean in my
town it's so small that there's not
enough churches to access to everything
because it's driving distance and um
that's been the hardest part of my in my
community as I'm living there so is it
is a big issue
so thank you um does anyone have any
other
questions just one okay Senator go ahead
thank you for your testimony and the
work that you're trying to do you did a
really good job thank you um so in your
case because everybody's different and
their needs and what they're hoping to
accomplish is very different but you
really embrac that college dormatory
type space and that's something that you
would be happy in is that correct yes if
yeah in sh sharing about her college
experience I think that she was wanting
to express and correct me if I'm wrong
that she was independent she could walk
wherever she wanted she could go to
stores hang out with friends take a bus
um wherever she wanted um but she does
apartment thank you thank you any other
questions okay Mr no Mr Yella all right
representative y excuse me that's
fine
um thank you uh for coming I am
interested
in interested in kind of where it seems
like you're currently living at home MH
with your parents and you're you uh you
have a a job and you're you looking or
into um moving and finding a place that
um where I guess uh where have you been
looking have you looked at any of the um
the uh like towns around where you're
currently working or are you um and are
you actively currently looking um or is
there some other barrier like the
transportation that kind of rules out
the some of the towns that you would
maybe want to move to yeah I mean for me
it's just been really difficult because
a lot a lot of PE places in New Hamster
don't really have
transportation like if you were going to
the St Boston yes there is but um I have
have looks online on Z and um and other
apps too but the like the the numbers
are so high that it could be complicated
because people like me have to pay rents
and other people have to pay their own
rent so um with my job my checks are
mostly Sav during my time at work and
I'm using
stable account which is really helpful
um
it's like you can actually save money on
your stable account for things like
college stuff um you could save it for
school stuff and everything like that so
that that has help me a lot during this
time
okay good you said that you're saving
for college stuff is there do you
have um are you trying to go back to
college or do you have college debt that
you're trying to pay off what what um
what education things are you trying to
save for and what are your goals there
I'm trying to say for apartment okay
it's mostly apartment yeah okay yeah
representative yella next week we're
going to hear from the people who
administer the stable account so you can
hear all all about that okay right any
further
questions okay thank you very much and
we have your contact inform you will
surely be hearing from us again yes
thank you so much for coming today thank
you appreciate it all right Mr wood are
are you willing to come and testify
thank you um Senator richardi is going
to have to leave at 3 so we kind of have
a we're in kind of a time crunch here so
if um you know folks could keep their uh
comments kind
tight that would be
helpful so if you would state your name
and tell us where you live good
afternoon Madam chair woman my name is
Thomas wood and I am a uh resident of
der Derry here in New
Hampshire and I live independently out
in the
community as a
66-year-old with lifelong physical and
and I live in a manufactured
home in a uh tenant
Cooperative the frost residence
Cooperative was which is diagonally
across from the uh from the historic
Robert Frost farm in
Derry and my issues with
housing is not
is was it that uh you know is it after
paying my rent and also was it utilities
you know
that you know and I'm also was it paying
for was
it I have two major was it uh if how
well internal infrastructure was it was
it the repair payments you know that I'm
still working working the pay off cuz a
year ago I I had to replace the uh the
electric water heater in my uh in my
house and I also had to have the
uh the uh the heat exchange when in my
furnace
replaced you know the water heater was
not under
warranty you know the uh the furnace was
still under warranty cuz my home was
built
was manufactured in uh
2016 and so was it the the the heat
exchange part was free but the labor
charge was like uh 1,700
bucks and also the price for the water
heater and the and the and the and the
3600 and so like uh I had the situation
where was
it I after I uh pay these bills and pay
pay what I can for was it the uh
property tax paying for the
water and I do have an 82-year-old
elderly
roommate Mr
cuml who who lives with me otherwise he
would be completely homeless and on the
street you know is it because several
years ago his third wife's was it the
kids kicked him out of the
uh one of the mobile the manufactured
home he was living in in the frost
residence
Cooperative sold it to somebody else you
know and it somebody else bought it and
then he was living with with the with
his uh sister who who also eventually
died a few months later and he ended up
having to take come with come back with
and live with me in order to have a
place to live and also what it he
assists me with the
expenses I pay him about 400 between
$400 and $500 a month so that's a fixed
expense for me to take pay him back they
help him pay for the uh pay for other
utilities like the the phone the uh
cable TV and internet and also the the
electric bill CU it's under his those
are under his name but the uh oil and
the uh hot water and and the water under
my names and of course the property tax
and I own my house
outright but I pay
$380 per month for the lot rent which is
also the amenities fee for the frost
residence
Cooperative so every single month I
myself am broke and of course miss my
roommate Mr
cuml is also was it broke by the time he
was it pays off his medical bills and
all his was it uh expenses which include
you know the upkeep and maintenance of a
vehicle and of course I do not
drive I used to drive you know was it
and but I gave up the uh driving so that
will you are you willing to take some
questions from us yes so are you are on
disability right now so yes I Social
Security Disability I AG 66 okay I have
been on
65 okay
and
my I was originally living with my
younger brother Nathaniel who was uh who
passed away in 2020 not from covid but
from a massive heart attack because his
insurance company stopped paying for his
insulin and he was rationing it hoping
nothing bad would
happen I'm so sorry he was my primary
care original caregiver you know to ass
assist me out I'm so sorry about that
does anyone have you have a question for
Mr wood representa thank you thank you
for your testimony um
did so you previously had um
someone taking care like your family M
your your brother taking care of you or
helping helping you or do you in me you
know do you do you uh and that that is
currently being taken care of by your
your roommate and and not so much you
know what I'm more I'm more or less on
my own with it but my roommate we well
we share the expenses you know you know
to try to have a little bit of a quality
of life you know with it but you know
right now my roommate is in the hospital
in
CMC and he's going to be operated on you
know as it
tomorrow you know it and there's a good
chance that he'll end up was it uh
physically disabled either was was it
losing Toes or losing a
foot okay
so do you do you feel like you currently
um have the assistance that you need
to
uh live independently or do you think
that the the loss of your brother I just
need assistances with housekeeping okay
primarily and also rides out into the
community okay and you don't you're not
currently having that and so that's
something that you're I do need I am I
am in the uh Manchester Transit
authorities cart Paratransit service
system okay but you have to take an at
least call at least 24 hours in advance
to book a roundtrip ride to to get
anywhere and I'm trying to take and
get get a hold of the community
caregivers Elder services in Derry know
that they get me other rides out into
the
community plus also was it I've tried
over the last few
years to get uh assistance through was
it the uh was it Community c commun
community
Crossroads in uh I believe there in
ainson that to try to assist
me but you know as it these things have
all pretty much all fallen through
because there's the attitude that people
see me as a person on with M Cal poliy
and Mild autism as not disabled enough
to KN to to the even at my age of 66 to
to need
services and of course I me and my
family over the last last half century
have
had major Mega issues with dealing with
this state with trying to get
services for oh was it a mentally ill
parent who should have been
institutionalized in the the Hampshire
State
Hospital you know as it in
1966 and should have been helped and the
family should have been helped and taken
care and and taken care of you know is
it and my father father helped
instead was it me and my younger brother
Nathaniel we ended up was it uh being
mental hospital orderlies from a very
young age
all the way up till was it our our
2008 and the something that the state
should have been doing to help to with
help her and with treat her and get her
happened and I'm and was it this is one
of the reasons why I do not trust the
state of New Hampshire to
takeen was it when I asked for help to
takeen get the help I
need I'm sorry to that's my major
beef I'm sorry to hear about and I as I
said I'm living independently in the
community as best I can more or less on
my
own thank you very much does anyone have
questions okay representative
L thank you for sharing your story with
us um if you when you think about the
future and where would you like to live
independently would you like to stay
where you are or would you imagine
living in another
Community I would like to stay where I
am you know as
it but one of the things that I'm going
to need in the near future is I need a
wheelchair ramp and I have no money to
one as my body
mobile thank you to keep me in my home
thank you thank you very
much thank you for coming today we
really appreciate your testimony that
insightful all right next next person I
have on my list is uh Jessica margeson
um and Rachel gagy I don't know if you
want to come up together or
independently if we could come up
I swear that's as contagious when you
cough as someone yawning um hi my name
is Jessica marison I'm a tenant Advocate
organizer in Manchester New Hampshire
and for the past 3 years and in a few
months now I've run a tenant Clinic um
and in the tenant Clinic I've met um
many many people um I've seen many
things and I would like to give my
opinion on some of those things that
I've seen and
noticed um we in this room represent
many different disabilities our housing
options need to be as varied as possible
to support all levels or needs I wanted
to make sure I address that all
disabilities are different all needs are
different and if we can make sure that
what is right for each individual is
able to be attained I think that's what
we're reaching for here um what I see
with I love the Fair Housing Act and the
help that nhla has um with helping the
residents of New Hampshire but
unfortunately what I sadly see is when
they have a claim that they contact that
group and they try and work through I've
had residents evicted before they got
anywhere with pressing that fair housing
act claim one of them recently um was a
family of three uh four total the
elderly father's now in a
shelter um who is on oxygen and the rest
of the family we were able to get
luckily after a week of being locked out
into an apartment I had a understanding
landlord
luckily um emotional service animals I
have the biggest difficulty with those
um for my tenants I have honestly what I
tell them now because if you look at the
definition of an emotional support
animal they are not termed an animal or
a pet that is something um equal to a
wheelchair a cane a device so I I
explain that to them and I tell them
don't even tell them you have a cat
because you have a medical device you
move in they try and kick you out we do
a reasonable accommodation and fight it
because getting them in there with the
emotional service animal has been a
fight people are getting turned down
left and right um and how do you fight
that when you're just fighting to stay
house you have to focus on the first
things first and that's getting a roof
over your head and a lot of these
landlords know this um one thing I think
would be helpful for those of us I am
myself am on disability I've met with
Senator the Sheen's office and
Congressman Pap's office in DC I think
that when one applies for disability
there should be a box that they can
check that housing is needed and once
the disab ility rights are granted it
should be automatically enrolled into a
housing or public housing of some sort
maybe there's something the state can do
um since the federal government isn't
and when those are on disability they
have some type of we need some type of
office to go to because the other thing
I wanted to talk about is Section 8 the
average person applies they're on the
waiting list eight years the best those
on disability can get is a 2-year weight
list but that's still too long if they
know the Avenues to go to have somebody
help expedite their case meaning there's
certain paperwork that doctors or other
professionals can do I've done it twice
luckily where you can help
expedite um their case and you basically
list out everything that's wrong and why
it's so important to get them into
housing and why that depends on it that
can help expedite a voucher but they
have to have um a particular doctor or a
social working agency that can do it not
everyone has access to that so having a
state agency where they could call up
and have help getting that paperwork
done would be helpful with housing
programs
um and the gentleman was right you can
only have a car or a house now it's too
hard to have both I also had to give up
my car um with disability my income
after they deduct my Medicaid or my
medicare is only
1362 um I would only then income qualify
for a little over $400 on an apartment
I'm not going to find that I have to
work luckily I have
um a skill set of tenant rights because
I had volunteered for many years doing
that on my own and have been been able
to have work in that um this past
January they decided that I made $200 a
month too much and took away my
disability in January I had to go a
month with a lowered pay I lost my
housing during that that month because I
couldn't pay for my room rental I was in
my car got back into a room for rent
room for rents can be joke sometimes
when people are desperate you can go
into not the best situation so I spent a
total of seven weeks living in my
vehicle this um beginning this year
during winter time until I could find a
room that I could rent
um because that whole thing got set off
I had to lower my income by 200 a month
I finally got my disability back I have
a glass ceiling because of my disability
I can only make so much that doesn't
allow me to compete with others when it
comes to trying to get an apartment I'm
lucky enough to have a good landlord now
where I rent a room in a shared housing
situation um my rent is $900 a month it
includes my utilities I'm very lucky to
have it I don't know how many places
like this across Manchester that are
actually safe to be in also
um evictions there's no safety net one
of the biggest things I have to explain
to people on misinformation is there's
no safety net for winter a lot of people
still assume that you can't be evicted
during winter the next they assume is
that if you're disabled or elderly there
is a safety net there so those don't end
up on the street that's not true I
currently work at a shelter in
Manchester and I can tell you that is
definitely not true um there's a good
majority of people there that are
disabled um I can't speak too much on
that without my boss is okay um but my
tenants that I work with was my tenant
Clinic um the things I have seen of
people of landlords evicting tenants is
been horrible um there's a few of them
to this day that two years later they're
still homeless waiting to get some type
of Housing
and because of no um net out there
renovation of victions are making it
worse for those of us with this ability
because it's a threat that's easily done
um so for instance just recently I
helped somebody with a 540A they got on
their
540A um they ended up in court for
eviction because the whole electric
needed to be changed out so the
renovation eviction was going to go
through I was lucky enough to make him a
deal with the help of nhla where they
had seven months of rent taken care of
but that's if you have those exact
moments there they had the 540A they had
me they had nhla not everybody has that
um but they have two and a half months
left to find a place and that's a mother
who is
disabled um the fiance just had to have
major surgery himself I don't know how
they're going to move in a couple months
but that's what they face so if they
complain about any issues we're
terrified too because the next thing is
a renovation eviction and where are we
going to go after that there's no safety
nets the shelters are full there's
weight list on every one of them
um and last um because of this there are
people out there taking advantage of
those on disability right now in
Manchester um just to be safe I don't
want to mention the person's name um but
I've spoke with many
people that have been through it or know
those who have this person will find
those who are on disability to get them
into his their housing it's $200 a week
sometimes um on disability you can bring
home a range of 700 a month sometimes
lower even all the way up to like 1,700
the range is in there um so for someone
that's only at 900 a month they're left
with about $100 a month to meet all
their basic needs
also um and this brings us to Rachel I
wanted it to be up here to give Rachel
support okay thank you
okay Rachel are you ready to testify I
guess so
yeah thank you for
coming okay my name is Rachel gagy I am
disabled I became disabled as of
200 200 2008 I had two heart attacks by
then I had two
strokes and nine
bypasses because I have got a two blood
disorders one is antix phospherous lied
lupus what it does is it causes your
blood to run real thick and pasty like
toothpaste so I got a lot of blood clots
I had to go in for a double bypass on my
hip but they had to do a catheter test
because my heart was
congested and that's what brought on the
two heart
attacks it damaged three vental
Valves and one of them was my a itic
valve your aor
valve and they were doing all right for
the
past 8 16 years
and couple years ago when we were
evicted because of a renovation eviction
now all the stress has caused it to
become very
congested it turned it from Jello to
concrete
so in 2 days I have to go in for a valve
replacement because it's got a small
slit that's only letting a little bit of
blood
out
so
um took me two years to find an
apartment because the rents are so
high I have got three social securities
I got mine my husband's and my
granddaughter
okay me and my husband are both disabled
my grand granddaughter's got Survivor
because her father had
died between the three of us we're
barely making e barely making it we're
lucky if we got five bucks left by the
fifth of the month and that has to last
us the entire
month okay our rent is 1750 a month we
only make 3150
so the rent takes up just about all of
it we barely make enough to I say most
of my light bill I I'm lucky if I can
put 25 bucks on it a month I got a shut
off notice by the 24th that I have to
pay on and I don't even know how I'm
what Rachel wanted to stress was that
um with her heart condition for 15 years
it was doing okay and over the past
three years of the stress of being
homeless for two years and fighting to
get in her current place it exacerbated
her condition to where she has to have a
valve replacement so it talks about um
the disabilities that are worsened um
especially with those that are homeless
with diabetes I see many missing toes
and feet um because they're not able to
properly care for insulin and food and
taking care of them um her income
qualifying when they moved into her
current apartment it was $300 less a
month but then the first year of living
there it went up
300 um so if they were to try and income
qualify to move again they probably with
the way rent is right now they may not
qualify definitely for their place but
for another it'd be kind of shaky and
she currently lives with many repairs
that need done but her fear of reporting
those
okay right now we just moved from the
second floor to the first floor because
I have to go in for that operation yeah
so I talked to my landlord you know when
the apartment came open cuz my land my
doctor don't want me doing a lot of
stairs he was nice enough to let me go
downstairs and but there's a lot of
repairs that need to be done and I told
them okay like with the windows we used
to make Windows me and my husband I
saids if you get me the parts we can fix
those windows because the balances each
there's five out of six windows that
need the balances to be replaced we can
fix those all you got to do we told them
where to go who to talk to to get those
balances all you got to do is go and
talk to them and get them we can install
them the screens I made screens for 10
years I can fix those screens for you
mhm just give me the material all you
got to do is go to Walmart and get the
stuff cost you 20 bucks to get all of
it he doesn't want
to he's been blowing me off for the past
month and the plumbing needs to be fixed
because the van the vanity in the
bathroom keeps plugging up the tub and
sink in the
kitchen I there something's wrong with
the plumbing if you get the
piping the pipes we can fix it because
we did M maintenance for our old
landlord for 24 years so we can fix it
if you get the
stuff okay if it needs professional work
we got a friend who is certified plumber
we can call
him now in our granddaughter's room you
need an electrician we have a friend who
is a certified electrician we can call
him and he can fix those you got three
Outlets that work when they feel like it
plus you can take your fingers and pop
them right out of the
wall not good okay so something's wrong
there you need a certified electrician
here he knew it from the first day he
showed me the
apartment it keeps blowing it off I'm
ready to
call Kevin who is a building inspector
in
Manchester but if I
do he's going to want a he's basically
going to condemn that apartment cuz
something is wrong with the plumbing
something is wrong with the electric
electricity where am I going to
go I would have to leave the
apartment I can't afford another
apartment I can barely afford the one I
do and then he'll evict me for
it or what did he say if he does certain
repairs he'd have to raise he told me he
says if I keep having to put repairs in
your Apes I'll have to ra raise the rent
he raises it anymore he ain't going to
be able to afford it have either of you
applied for um housing V
I have yeah how long I I have another
two years to wait for
it and Jessica have you I'm on the
waiting list they told me eight years um
she was told two years it's been almost
two years but now they're still telling
her another
two and I and just in case there's an
issue with this um uh currently housing
has a new thing where they're able to go
online and sign in and can say that they
want to stay on this waiting list and
make any changes needed when I went in
to help Rachel with hers they had her
income at 3.8
million there was something that
happened in the conversion or something
so there might be other people that are
experiencing this that possibly could be
why she's lower on the waiting list
because the income is not necessitating
anything we did change it though I don't
know how many other people are running
into stuff like this so I just wanted to
bring it to someone's attention in case
needed so when you applied was that with
New Hampshire housing or was it with
Manchester housing both okay okay I
commonly in the tenant Clinic we'll have
the tenants sign up for both um New
Hampshire housing tends to be a little
quicker but they're different vouchers
and then we go to the next rung you got
places like Beach Hill property
Metropolis Property Management places
like that around the community that
offer um the 50 60% Ami housing where
you have a minimum and a maximum and
then they also usually offer the 30% Ami
where they pay 30% of their income so
what it looks like is getting them on
all the different levels so they can be
somewhere while they wait and even those
community-based projects are easily one
to two years waight lless too okay wow
does anyone have any
questions I know you've got to
go yeah
okay just a quick one what did you say
that was Ami area median income and so
there are programs that your rent is
based on that in a community program
yeah it's uh Workforce housing is looked
at more as 50 and 60% so like beachill
property is a great one to explain it
with they have um two different programs
there they have one where you have to
meet a minimum but you can't go over
that maximum and that's the 50 60% range
and then they have the other program um
where you would pay 30% of your income
that's similar to a HUD
program thank you okay um but I'd also
like to bring up that there's many
Project based
housing communities that are losing
their um they're always set for anywhere
from 10 25 30 some years there's a lot
of communities that are losing that cost
effective part so there's going to be a
lot more
people facing homelessness disabled and
elderly thank you okay all right thank
you both for coming that was really
informative okay so I have a whole list
of folks here um I have
um I have some folks we've heard from
before like lri Macintosh but I'm really
interested in getting people who um who
else would like to testify and um okay
all right okay I'm I'm hoping to get at
least get the folks with disabilities
first I'm a parent okay okay so but okay
you can go after anybody who has a
direct disability okay that's okay all
right thank
you thank you um can you please state
and
okay yes thank you so much for allowing
me to speak to you today my name is Ryan
dony I am an AB advocacy coordinator
someone hi I'm sorry um thank you
community members my name is Jennifer
croll c r o w l l and i u work for Grant
State independent living as the peer
support coordinator and I also am in our
access modification program so we help
people we are means of resort with
funding but we do um I'm on the
committee to help folks that need
modifications in their home to live
safely thank you so much uh so certainly
we've heard a lot about the issues
around
affordability with our with our house
housing crisis but uh accessibility is
just as important as well uh and just to
give you a a bit of data here so the uh
US Department of Housing and Urban
Development HUD periodically uses the
American housing survey to assess the
stock of homes accessible to those with
people with
disabilities the
2019 American housing survey data shows
that almost two in 10 US households
include a person with accessibility
needs so this may be someone like me who
uses a wheelchair a walker cane whatever
uh but of those households 4 in 10
reported that their homes do not have
accessible accessibility features such
as entry-level bedrooms or full
bathrooms so we've got a lot of folks
out there like me who are living in
places that are just not equipped for us
and we've got no where else to
go only a very small share of households
reported plans to install such features
or to make accessibility related
improvements to their homes uh obviously
there are home modification programs out
there but funding is limited and you
know there's there's only just so much
folks in July 2023 three a hearing held
by the Senate special committee on Aging
in Congress found that
26% of the US population identify as
having a
disability by 2030 one in5 Americans
will be over the age of
65 and keeping these numbers in mind the
committee found that less than 5% of the
National Housing Supply is accessible
and less than 1% is what folks would
consider to be wheelchair friendly so
that 5% you know they might have a ramp
to get in they might just have uh an
entry level that's Street know that's
that's street level uh but the bathroom
might not be accessible there may not be
a bedroom on the first floor things like
that so now how do we address this how
do we how do we solve this problem
retrofitting older homes and most of our
homes are quite old is just
prohibitively expensive in a lot of
cases it just doesn't make sense so I
think the real solution to all of this
is really hammering home the idea of
supporting Universal Design and getting
uh contractors and property developers
to really get get behind this if even
you know one or two% of new developments
adhere to Universal designs so that you
know everything that's vital is on the
first floor
uh wider wider hallways wider
doorways bathrooms with uh no slit
material things of that nature u i mean
these are going to be great not only for
folks like me and Jenny but will also
allow people to you know find a home
move into a home and age in that home
you know because we want we want people
to be able to live in their homes for
for their whole lives it's what a lot of
people want and unfortunately again a
lot of situations where somebody's
living in a home and they get older or
they have an accident or something God
forent and now that home doesn't work
for them
anymore so uh you know
obviously that's something that's going
to take time you know for these new
buildings to to be built and all that
but I think I think it really is the the
most effective solution to to this
particular accessibility problem and I'd
have okay does Jennifer want to speak
first and then we can ask questions of
you all right I just want to give an
example of being on the um our amp
committee our access modification
committee program committee we get our
biggest um requests are and when I say
we are the means of Last Resort so when
they come through Granite State
Independent Living we do try to re to
search out other access to funds for
folks our biggest two are ramps and
bathrooms ramps can range from
$4500 to $99,500
that's for one ramp in a single home to
be safe for someone to get in and out of
their home bathroom modifications can
range from 5,000 to
$10,000 now I do want to let you know
that it is not medically
necessary according to the state that a
person has to have a
bathroom they can have a shower C Chair
by their bed and can take a bed
bath so these are these are obstacles
that people people face every single day
I sustained a spinal cord injury 16
years ago I was 26 years old live in my
dream at that time and and enjoying life
and and the blink of a eye I had an
accident that um that uh uh sustained a
spinal cord injury did I ever think that
this was going to happen of course not
did my family ever think this was going
to happen definitely not but I am very
grateful for my family and friends as I
have been able to have us very strong
support system and so for me I do live
independently on my own and that just
happened about four and a half years ago
I did get my own place with my my dog
and um with a caregiver that lives
beside me that would be the only way I'd
be able to do this um but as far as
funding I had to get um I had to get a a
second you know out that safe for me so
I had to get a ramp put on the back of
that um doorways for me to be able to
get in easy as my hands don't function
the same way anymore my bathroom needed
to be modified I needed to get um uh
need to make sure my My Fire EX um my um
just you know that it was safe fire for
fire for Access um in and out safely two
different ways these were a lot of
things that cost a lot of money and to
find funding for this now um earlier
they mentioned CFI choices for
Independence it's a wonderful program
that people can have and they do help
with a lot of funding but again it's
another obstacle a lot more paperwork
that people have to go through luckily
at Grant State Independent Living we
have a really great support system that
we will help folks that are consumers
figure out this paperwork but I myself
can speak from Pure experience it's very
stressful every year I have to restate
yes I'm disabled no I'll never walk
again yes I need need help taking a
shower yes I need help getting dressed
yes I need help preparing my food yes I
need help going to the bathroom why do I
have to state that all the time and
every year and I am not the only one
that goes through this and to have that
all taken away from you and then to just
try to have a little bit of Independence
again in your life and it gets taken
even further away from you because
there's no way you can afford it there's
no way you can get in it there's no way
you can maneuver there's no way you can
park these are just obstacles and these
just add one by one by one so it's so
each and every obstacle just adds on the
paperwork and you're just a piece of
paper and that's what you are until you
make your voice heard until you advocate
for yourself and by you all um the
members of your committee allowing us to
be able to come up here and speak on beh
to of myself and others is a great
Advantage for everybody and I just would
like for you to know that at Grant and
state Independent Living we do have many
programs for people but there are many
others that are out there that offer
it's just finding the resources and
finding the help and that can be really
difficult as
well okay thank you does anyone have any
questions okay representative L
montin thank you um
oh thank you do you um I didn't catch it
are you an employee of the agency help
with other people and how does your
organization uh raise money to do what
you do yes ma'am I I am the peer support
coordinator at Granite State Independent
Living I've been there for eight years
now uh we dabble in a lot of the
programs at Granite State um and as an
in the only Independent Living Center
here in New Hampshire we are non profit
organization so we work highly on
fundraising you're
welcome representative
yella yes thank you
um you said that
you uh live independently as of four
years ago what was
your um situation before and how long
did
were you trying to achieve
this the stable place that you have now
um and what barriers or anything that
you can share that Lessons Learned kind
of a thing that might you know shed shed
light on kind of
where um we
might uh look for either Solutions or or
or identify kind of the problems like
the scope of problem yes so I um I with
the luck of my family I was able to move
home with my parents they fully
renovated um the house uh to the best of
their ability our ramp is not
Ada but it's
doable um only in the
winter um but uh no so uh it took it
took um it well I actually got put I
signed up to be put on a weit list and
that weight list was 2 to six years to
find a place that' be accessible for me
now not only did I need to find a place
that was accessible for me but I also
needed to find at least a two-bedroom
apartment because I would have need to
have have a living caregiver during this
time living at my parents I do have um
Personal Care attendance through Grant
State Independent Living so I am also a
consumer of theirs so I did have people
helping me morning afternoon and night
um getting me up getting me going and
getting me back into bed with that with
that help I was able to also be able to
get back to work now um the two to year
I was looking into conquer Manchester
nashaa these are all um cities that are
very far I I'm live in antrum a small
town but it's small in quaint and it's
where I grew up and and where my heart
is so that 2 to six year weight was very
difficult and then I looked at the price
range and with what I make and with what
I get with SSDI there would have been no
possible way without the help of if um
if I was to ask my parents to help me
with paying rent and um as each year
goes on 26 27 28 years old 29 years old
I'm really not still wanting to ask my
parents to help me um not that they
wouldn't if this is what I really wanted
they laid it on the table for me that if
we were to find a home within the area
that would be able to be modified to
work good for me but to stay close to my
family so I'm not far away in case of
emercy
would I be up for that and I said of
course I would so we searched for I
think it took almost a year for us to
find a home um that would work perfectly
and it did it ended up panning out and
it took us only about eight months to
make it um accessible my dad's quite a
good handyman and with being in a small
town um small town love so they came in
to help us well with making it even more
accessible for me to get into my house
so I would say the first is the way list
the weight list is um
terrifying and then you look at the cost
and the cost of rent is twice as
terrifying um and uh I also wanted to
continue to be able to work but I'm not
sure if that would have been able to
happen either if I move further away
from my Offices here in conquer um but
working remotely from home mostly so um
question does anyone have any questions
Donnelly okay um I would ask if you
could email us all those wonderful
numbers yep I will that will help us
okay thank you very much I Mo has my
email address so okay thank you very
much oh you're welcome thank you for
coming today and thank you for waiting
okay Carrie would you please come
good
afternoon my name is Carrie Duran I live
in wolfboro New Hampshire and as you can
see from today's hearing I wear a lot of
hats I am the legislative Lea on for
Lakes Region Community Services I'm also
a parent volunteer with the New
Hampshire Council on developmental
disabilities but my most important job
is that of Mom I'm a single mom of three
amazing girls my youngest daughter Katie
who I just shared some photos with you
she's in the center she is
quintessential the 13 Going on 30 uh she
was born with Down Syndrome I am her a
full-time caregiver I just recently
started working full-time so I'm
balancing all of that as a single parent
my twin girls Isabella and muddy Soul
just went off to college and super proud
of them but I'm sharing photos of them
to show you just what some of the many
faces of the New Hampshire housing
crisis looks like because not only am I
here as a parent thinking ahead for my
daughter Katie who has big big dreams
and as her parent I here to make sure
those happen as best as I can and help
her to advocate for herself she wants to
have her own apartment she wants to have
her driver's license she wants to have
go to college have a job get married
have a family and I'm very concerned as
to what her future is going to look like
uh once I'm no longer um the primary
support person in her life um where is
she going to be able to live affordably
where um as um my friend Laura um spoke
about you know where is going to be
accessible for her wolf bro is very
rural there's not a lot of sidewalks on
the side roads except for in town at the
moment but I'm thinking ahead as to what
her options will be what choices will be
where does she want to live either in
the city or in a rural area and even for
myself being um a lower income single
mom I've struggled finding housing for
the three of us I am fortunate enough
that I live in Herman Hill in wolfboro
which is part of Lakes Region Community
developers I've lived there for 10 years
um and it is uh an income based
Workforce housing um community that I
absolutely love it's beautiful I feel
very fortunate to live there and
currently Lakes Region Community
developers is working on another phase
of the development that would
include uh Supportive Housing for people
with developmental disabilities my
daughter Katie is served through uh our
local area agency which is Northern
Human Services not the agency I work for
Lakes Region Community Services
and so Northern is working and
partnering with um Lakes Region
Community developers our biggest hurdle
and I know you've heard this is at all
the local meetings that I've attended um
in the town of wolfboro and other areas
when Supportive Housing or
non-traditional types of residents um
whether uh they are persons with
disabilities or mental health concerns
or uh perhaps uh recovering from
substance abuse any kind of Supportive
Housing there's a stigma and I am
hearing all the time the knot in my
backyard so I go constantly my kids
growing up they're like Mom you're going
to another town meeting can you just
stay home and but I would drag them
everywhere because I thought it was
important that people see the faces of
those who live in lower income housing
or Supportive Housing and that's me and
my kids my daughters uh who are 18
starting out in college someday I'm
going to be passing the torch to them in
looking out for their younger sister and
I really want to make sure that through
the work of this committee and beyond
that there are choices um not only for
my daughter Katie but for my daughters
once they graduate high
school they already graduated high
school I can't believe it um once they
graduate College they are not even sure
how they are going to afford to live
somewhere and then taking on potentially
in their future um caring for their
sister and what is that going to look
like and how are they going to be able
to afford it um so as a mom I have a lot
of concerns I it was such a pleasure to
be here today to listen to all the
amazing Advocates um in the room and the
testimonies as you can see there's so
many facets of this concern the housing
crisis it we could all be here for days
and days as you imagine um learning
about all the different facets but um
again I'm so grateful to have been here
today and just to show you the faces of
my family and and what our concerns are
thank you for the opportunity to speak
today thank you very much welcome happy
to take any questions um next week we're
hoping to hear from developers um
uh do you have contact information for L
region Community developers I do because
I serve on their board I'm currently the
chair okay of their board so I'd be
happy to um speak with our executive
director I'm I'm a joiner I volunteer a
lot to help you know make change in my
community so yeah I'm happy to reach out
her name is is Carmen
Loren and I will um put you in in touch
and see if she can come okay because
that would be terrific all right thank
you yes you're welcome representative
yella yes thank you um I'm definitely
com uh interested in the um development
that you have and um we had we heard a
lot of um discussion I guess about um
like the walkability and and the um the
the proximity to services and stuff like
that and then also kind of uh interested
in
how how much of the development is
Workforce housing versus um
Market um is that you know 25% or can
you give me some idea of so I I don't
have the exact figures but I can I know
most of my neighbors um that it is Prim
primarily Workforce housing the primary
residents are all families but there are
also people with disabilities and
several um retired uh folks that live
there as well um and it is primarily
Workforce lower income um you do have to
meet a certain threshold of income to be
able to live there and then you can't
make you know pass a certain amount as
well so but I think Carmen can certainly
give you those facts and figures if she
comes next
time thank you um I wanted to offer too
if you wanted to take a field trip and
see a beautiful Housing Development that
I am very proud to say is my home I'm
happy to show you
around yeah well um thank you we we we
have a full year after we do our
preliminary report to to to to do
further investigation so thank thank you
for that of course happy to thank
you thank representative Lon yeah thanks
just for the record um you work for um
Lakes Region Community
Services um I'm chairperson of the board
for Lakes Region Community
developers okay but yes there's a lot of
Lakes Region Lakes Region Community
Services is not one of the area agencies
it is one of the area agencies but your
daughter is served by um Northern Human
Services okay yes it's a
lot it is okay all right um are I have a
list of well thank you so much thank you
very much okay so I have a list of names
here um um I I'm I'm not sure everybody
that did everyone who sign in wish to
testify here okay all right okay um well
then I want just go through the list is
anyone else would anyone else like to
point okay good right does anybody have
anything else to say before we adjourn
the meeting I'm a little concerned that
not that someone people might have had
to leave early and since there was a lot
of people that came to testify obviously
it's hard to
um that people may have time constraints
but we have at least one more meeting
right yes that um anyone
that had to leave early could could
still come and and testify or obviously
submit written testimony if they're
watching uh you know catching the last
of it even though they had to leave yeah
right that well and and again my name is
Kathy stab and if you go to the um um
you go to the general court website you
can get my contact information from
there you know it's I can never remember
what it is but maybe be put on the
agenda so that they can get know when
their okay time is maybe yeah that would
be good yeah yeah so next week we're we
are going to be hearing from um about
the stable program and um we're going to
um New Hampshire housing action is going
to connect us up with some Developers
who are going to speak with us next week
and hopefully you'll be able to bring
some folks too so that and that will be
our last meeting and then um after that
um you we have to we are we are supposed
to uh produce a report a preliminary
report by November 1st so I will we will
do everything in our power to make that
happen but um you know we've all got a
lot going on right now so but I I
definitely want it to be thorough rather
than you know worry about the the T you
know I'm going to try for for the
beginning of November but I want to make
sure that we get all the information
that should be in the report so that
anybody going forward from this point
will be able to um look at it and and
have a good idea of what needs to be
done okay anything
else from my uh do
you are you going to write the report
are we going to have a meeting to
discuss what's in the report how how is
the report
actually I mean if you want to write the
report
well yes I um well we yes we are
required to have um one more meeting um
I I wonder if maybe we could do a zoom
meeting and to just not have people I
don't I don't know if we can or should
we do sure about Zoom but okay you want
mean I don't know how you want to do it
I guess you're kind of in charge but I
think that
maybe I guess if you don't want to have
a a separate meeting for regarding it
like maybe having like people submit
their thoughts to you and then you could
draft something and then we can I don't
know if we have to vote to accept it or
what what what is the procedure as far
as that but I've been counting on you to
tell me that we're both
Ries I'm so I haven't been I haven't
been uh uh in charge of writing reports
are are on um study committees before so
I wouldn't know but I I'm sure
Paul uh or the speaker's office would be
able to let us know before the next
meeting how we should proceed you know
what I and as the chair I will look into
that thank you and um and um report back
next week and then you know maybe if
there's time at the end of the meeting
we can um have a a brief conversation
about you know what what things we want
to make absolutely sure are in the
report I will find out what needs to be
in the report I'm assuming that all of
the paper and so forth and uh stuff
that's been submitted um electronically
and so forth will need to be in the
report but I will find that out because
you know I definitely want to be
thorough and I want people to be able to
access all the in this information that
we've gotten from the stakeholders and
the impacted people thank you yeah okay
all right so motion to no further
business uh can we have a motion to
adjourn I motion to adjourn a second
okay all right thank you all for coming
and maybe we'll see some of you next
week and